hey what's going on guys I'm Jade
warshaw one of the co-hosts of the ramsy
show look we're always telling you the
most fun that you can have with money is
to give it so we are going to put that
to the test we went over to our local
Kroger grocery store and we're going to
see just how fun it is to give some
money away I came into Kroger grocery
store and I told Amy that we really just
wanted to know her opinion on inflation
and grocery store prices but Amy what we
really want to do is just tell you to
fill up your car and we would love to
bless you with whatever you can fit in
that
cart what actually I decided I think I
just want to buy you guys' groceries
today yes are you kidding we have a
really cool Christmas basket over here
that we'd like you guys to just fill up
with whatever you want we got to call my
mom and ask her what she wants what am I
going to do I'm going to get meat yes
get meat get the most expensive stuff
anything yes get what you want
girlfriend we are filling these carts up
this is so fun I we just need two no you
don't you need lots if that's what you
guys want us to do my kid uses these my
baby eats these yes get plenty for the
baby I know things I've been wanting to
buy and hadn't been able to buy yes look
she's doing the right thing she's just
throwing it in the
cart this is great what YouTube channel
you guys work for so it's called the
Ramsey Show Dave Ramsey H okay I took
his class last semester oh wow
foundations and personal finance wow wow
yeah the de uh the de Snowball Effect
that's the one I'm currently using right
now and it's health I mean it's health I
just came here to grab some lunch on my
lunch break where do you work we provide
insurance and things like that for
families of lower income housing or
whatever it may be that they can't
afford 10 care provides insurance
usually okay where's your card at it's
back there I was scared I wasn't going
to get it around hand time enough me
pushing your cart wasn't part of the
deal
now where you guys from uh we're from
Kenya okay cool my mom's from Somalia I
was born in Kenya it was born in Kenya
so you've got another younger sister is
it just a four of you guys I no it's 10
of us 10 of us wow I love that that is a
giant family this has been the funnest
Day of My Life free food
y'all who is sponsoring this is what I
want to know God is yeah God is
definitely God is you're right Amy you
did it oh my God I'd say that's a pretty
full cart good job what is this for cuz
we just want to be generous and this is
what we're supposed to do we're supposed
to bless people and you were so kind to
me when I rolled up on you in the
aisle I hope this was a blessing I'm
glad to see it is this is not going to
be a pretty face for
camera
blessings on
blessings all right two weeks of
groceries for 388 75 but we're also
feeding a family of what 11 how long do
you think this will last you you're good
yeah two months good several months we
don't have to go to the store for a
while Merry Christmas bless y'all thank
you Carol now how do I get these in my
car all right janaa we did not forget
about you cuz you have been the one like
ringing up all these groceries and
honestly watching all these people get a
blessing Merry
Christmas $500 I hope that you can find
something really great to do with that
we just hope that you have a Merry
Christmas yes
girl wow guys that was so incredible
look the cliche says it's more blessed
to give than receive and I can attest it
is so true that is the most fun with
money that I've had in a really long
time so look this season if you haven't
had a chance go and give go bless
someone's life it will truly be the most
fun you can ever have with money